all right we've been all music all hour
and we've got one more musical story to
finish things up this is what I'm
[Music]
liking a little over a year ago a group
of guys in Sweden were hanging out at a
bachelor party when they decided to
start singing unbeknownst to the group
one of the men recorded the whole scene
and put it up on Tik Tok just to show a
friend but more than one friend saw the
video in a few hours tens of thousands
had watched to date 22 million have
since since then they've become an
official group called Dad Harmony they
perform on radio shows and tour and they
still post videos like this amazing in
Saint
cover
cry I
do never SE
for
you again but I'm not like
them
finally get to love
somebody guess
what just hanging out with little
Spiderman on his lap we have this
amazing harmonizing dads on the line
right now everybody say hello to
Sebastian Peter Adam Thomas and
Michael what's up y'all I'm gonna I'm
gonna start with look I want to know
who's singing that base who who's
holding that down which one of you got
that voice come on now it's me hey
that's a sexy voice man it's a sexy face
well Peter I'm gonna start with you so
first like how did this video get
happen who posted it uh yeah it started
at my bachelor party we were in a hut
tub and we we sang the song The
wellerman as we usually do when we are
with each other and my brother Thomas
was posting this on TI TI Tok with his I
think seven followers at that time and
it all exploded and uh now yeah 22
million I love that you dudes were just
hanging out in a hot tub and you were
like we should probably sing we should
probably I love it so Sebastian Adam
like now you're performing and you're
touring right yeah I mean after it went
viral um we got uh invited to various uh
morning shows on television and radio
around the world and and uh from that on
it just kept going and now we're also
doing live
shows yeah unfortunately we do not bring
the kids with us on stage but they love
to join us uh when we sing at home I
know I love Spider-Man just laying on
the lap in the video that was a it's
just like in fire trucks there's
everything in the it's amazing um well
you sound beautiful your harmonies are
incredible um thank you so much for
posting and inspiring all of us and keep
singing I'm liking your post right now
and that's not all our season one
partner pilot pin makers of precise the
go to pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to honor truly Unstoppable dads
just like y'all so they're going to be
riding you a check for $1,000 which I
think is about like 10,500 Swedish Crona
so split that up how you will thank you
guys so much for joining us and thank
you to all our guests this hour Justin
timberlay Troy kasana baile and black B
now a great the not changing
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home